[Applause]
it's 39 days since we last heard from
donald trump
and boy have his supporters missed
[Music]
the former president has had five and a
half weeks to stew on defeat
and consider his future he might have
left the white house
but he isn't leaving politics
biden has failed in his number one duty
as chief executive
enforcing america's laws
this alone should be reason enough for
democrats to suffer withering losses in
the midterms and
to lose the white house decisively
four years from now
actually as you know they just lost the
white house but it's one of those things
but who knows who knows
i may even decide to beat them for a
third time okay
trump had points to make scores to
settle and old mistruth to pedal
we have a very sick and corrupt
electoral process
that must be fixed immediately this
election was rigged
and the supreme court and other courts
didn't want to do anything about it
by rights after losing the election by 7
million votes and having been impeached
for a second time
trump's political career should be dead
and buried
but it's not just look at this
in the end he took his supporters right
to the edge but stopped
just short of announcing his candidacy
in 2024
but what is clear is that the republican
party
is still trump's party and anybody who
got in his way
will be made to pay for it trump's
supporters are galvanized by a misplaced
sense of injustice and it works for him
this is a unique circumstance in the
united states it's the first time in
over a century
where you've had a president who lost
after serving one term
who then has a strong loyal base who
then wants to come back again
so actually it's been a little bit more
than a century so this is as we would
say modern day presidential
trump is playing the game keeping his
supporters waiting and america guessing
if he does want to run in 2024
there's plenty who will back him
[Applause]